angenehm
Hallo! Mein Name ist Meier!
Angenehm, Müller.
freut mich
Guten Tag, mein Name ist Müller!
Freut mich, Herr Müller.
grüßen
Schönen Tag. Tschüss.
Wer war die Frau, die du eben gegrüßt hast?
winken
Wer ist der Junge, der dir zuwinkt?
sich verabschieden
Es war mir ein Vergnügen, Sie kennen zu lernen.
Ich verabschiede mich jetzt.
kennen
Kennst du den neuen Bioladen an der Ecke?
Kennen lernen
Wie habt ihr euch kennengelernt?
Hallo! Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
treffen
Wir treffen uns um 19:00 Uhr vor dem Kino, okay?
vorstellen
Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue
Mitarbeiterin vorstellen.
der Besuch
Ich freue mich über deinen Besuch.
Besuch haben
Ich kann nicht.
Ich habe heute Abend Besuch zum Abendessen.
besuchen
Komm uns bald wieder besuchen!
einladen
Darf ich dich zum Essen einladen?
mitkommen
Wir gehen essen, kommt ihr auch mit?
geben
Können Sie mir bitte die Quittung geben?
Wärst du so gut und gibst die
Dokumente bei Herrn Müller ab?
Okay, geben Sie mir bitte Bescheid.
nehmen
Bist du bereit?
Ja, ich nehme die Jacke und komme mit.
Was wollen wir zum Nachtisch nehmen?
bringen
Kannst du bitte das Besteck bringen?
die Frage
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich
die Frage beantworten soll.
fragen
Darf ich Sie etwas fragen?
Ich denke, dass ich nach dem Weg fragen muss.
nachfragen
Ich habe es nicht verstanden und
musste noch einmal nachfragen.
bitten
Bitte Ruhe!
Kannst du mir bitte helfen?
schenken
Er hat mir zum Geburtstag Blumen geschenkt.
das Geschenk
Das ist ein schönes Geschenk.
der Dank
Vielen Dank für dein Geschenk!
danken
Danke für deine Hilfe
Nichts zu danken!
Sich bedanken
Ich möchte mich noch einmal sehr
herzlich für Ihre Hilfe bedanken.
keine Ursache
Keine Ursache
sich streiten
Sie streiten sich seit 30 Minuten.
der Streit
Ich möchte deswegen keinen Streit.
streiten
Ich will nicht mehr darüber streiten!
leid tun
Es tut mir leid, ich wollte nicht streiten.
Es tut mir leid, dass du dich mit
deiner Freundin gestritten hast.
die Entschuldigung
Entschuldigung, darf ich dich kurz stören?
verzeihen
Verzeihen Sie, wo geht es hier zum Bahnhof?
die Verzeihung
Verzeihung! Ich habe die falsche Nummer gewählt.
Wie viele Wörter kanntest du schon?
Hast du eine Frage?
Schreib sie in die Kommentare!
Und hinterlass uns ein Like!